[Musique]
aujourd'hui les relations sont très
abîmées
on a déjà vécu des situations analogues
dans l'histoire tourmentée des deux pays
qui ne parvient pas à parviennent pas à
se parler sereinement et c'est toujours
passionnée et passionnelle et c'est un
énième épisode un énième avis de tempête
sur les relations diplomatiques entre la
france et l'algérie peut-être que les
propos du prénom macron était un peu
excessif en tout cas peu diplomatique
même si je les partage pour reparti je
crois qu'il l'a pu tenir ce genre de
propos aussi d'abord parce que la france
a fait beaucoup de gestes depuis une
dizaine d'années et deuxièmement parce
qu'il sait que le régime actuel n'a pas
de légitimité par rapport à ses
concitoyens sans doute inconsciemment il
a évolué le présent maquereau a voulu
importe apporté son soutien au haras qu
il pouvait pas le dire explicitement
parce que là pour le coup ça aurait été
une ingérence flagrante mais pour autant
je crois que c'est une des
interprétations qu'on peut faire sur les
propos qu'a tenus le président macron et
d'ailleurs s'il avait voulu que ses
propos ne soient pas connus ou ne soient
pas rapportés il n'aurait pas invités à
la table au cours de ce déjeuner des
journalistes il a parfaitement le droit
de participer au débat mais pour autant
la manière dont il l'a fait n'était pas
très habile parce qu'elle contribue à
rallumer à réveiller le sentiment
national algérien du régime qui peut
grâce à cela faire l'unité autour de lui
et rassembler la population accepte et
la réconciliation c'est accepter
d'ouvrir grand les portes et les
fenêtres à la réalité à la lumière à la
vérité historique et ça c'est évidemment
on le comprend impossible et impensable
à ce stade pour autant la majorité de la
population algérienne qui n'a pas vécu
la guerre la tragédie de la guerre
d'algérie rit elle est dans une autre
perspective elle cherche à construire
une autre relation avec la france
[Musique]
où